you should have many questions at the
end of the first season of yellow
jackets everything you need to remember
going into season two is related to one
of them so when I thought about doing a
recap it made sense to organize it that
way there are also a lot of secrets so
before we dive into the questions a
brief overview of the basics will
hopefully bring you back to that remote
cabin in the Canadian wilderness and
modern day New Jersey 25 years later
the show is split and follows characters
over two timelines in 1996 it's a
coming-of-age tale wrapped up in a
survival story in 2021 you watch how
those 19 months they were stranded shape
their lives with the sense that they
brought whatever happened out there back
with them and it's still with them in
some way throughout there are shades of
psychological Thriller and horror
elements with hints of the supernatural
that fuel speculation about what's
really going on the characters are all
connected through the state champion
High School soccer team who were on
their way to Nationals when their plane
crashed the main characters or at least
the ones that appeared in both timelines
since the beginning are Shauna Who as a
teenager was best friends with Jackie
the captain and also most popular of the
yellow jackets by the end of the season
she's also the most dead or equally dead
as the coach or Laura Lee I suppose in
her memory and the way things were left
at the end of her life seemed to haunt
the adult Shauna who has been busy
burying her secrets and getting into new
messes which is something we'll come
back to her big secret in her teenage
years was that she was sleeping with
Jackie's boyfriend behind her back and
was pregnant at the time of the crash
taisa Who as a teenager was the star
player and came off as the most
competitive turn that into a successful
political career as an adult she was
carrying on a relationship with her
teammate van which they reveal field at
the Doom coming party which was after Ty
woke up in a tree to witness a wolf
attack and then tried to burn Van's body
on a funeral pyre thinking she was dead
and that did a great job of revealing
that she wasn't as an adult in an effort
to protect her campaign she secretly
hires Jessica Roberts to pose as a
journalist to make sure none of the
other survivors would spill the story of
what really happened when they were
stranded this led to all sorts of
problems but what's happening with Thai
sleepwalking is one of the biggest
questions that we have to get into
Natalie was the outcast of the bunch as
a teenager her secret was that she
pulled a gun on her father while he was
beating her mother and when he took it
away from her he accidentally shot
himself in the head and died in the
wilderness she forms a relationship with
Travis that continues into adulthood in
some sense but the other women refer to
it as toxic she has substance abuse
issues and has been in and out of rehab
multiple times by 2020 one she
cooperates with the others but is
somewhat of a foil since she can't
accept it Travis killed himself because
he promised her he would never do that
Misty for my money the most interesting
of the bunch by a large margin was the
lowly equipment manager that everyone
disliked as a teenager Misty is chaos
born out of a desire that will never be
satisfied her secret was that because
she was actually needed by the others
after the crash she decided to destroy
the plane's flight recorder when she
found it in the woods to this point in
the story The Other Women haven't found
out that she sabotaged their best chance
at being rescued in hopes that she could
finally be accepted as part of the group
this apparently didn't play out as
planned because Ty and Shauna still want
nothing to do with her as an adult that
desire to be needed extends to her
choice of occupation she works at an
assisted living facility as an adult who
spends her free time online with a
community of Citizen detectives
interestingly Miss was the only one who
was confirmed to be an active
participant in the cannibalism hinted
that in the pilot episode and curiously
that experience didn't curb her
enjoyment of beef jerky as an adult
there are a ton of other important
characters in both timelines and at
least six or so unnamed characters that
survived the plane crash that pop up
from time to time in the wilderness but
I think we'll catch up with most of them
as we get into these lingering questions
now that I've thrown out the c word in
relation to Misty it's time to talk
about the big question that's been
hanging over the yellowjacket series
from the very beginning who is the girl
that dies in the opening sequence she
finds her ending via some pungy sticks
at the bottom of a pit and we see her
hung up and drained of her blood in
preparation for what we can presume is a
much needed meal who this is is only the
first of a long list of questions that
come up I guess it's worth addressing
the idea that there might be some
misdirection involved considering the
actual this direction of showing her
wearing Jackie's heart necklace it's
remotely possible that this central
question that everyone keeps asking what
exactly did you have to do to survive on
your own for that extended period of
time it's possible that the answer to
that is not we ate our teammates but in
my mind the creators would have had to
have a very good reason to rest so much
on a rug pull that is to say we're led
to believe something terrible happened
something that hangs over their lives as
adults so if they aren't eating a human
being with the antler Queen then the
twist would almost have to be that the
truth is somehow worse and if you try to
put together a list of things worse than
hunting down people you know and
consuming them what do you have that
sits above that what's great about
revealing this at the beginning is that
cannibalism in a survival situation
isn't as Unthinkable as we'd like it to
be the survival Instinct is strong and
with a group of starving people it would
only take take one of them to get things
started what stands out here is that
they appear to be hunting her and it
seems organized enough to make you think
this might not be their first time so
the big questions here aren't whether
they're cannibals or their victim's
identity although if I had to guess I'd
say Mari given the appearance of dark
hair and the little bit of development
we've got on her makes her not
completely irrelevant to the point that
she wouldn't be missed but her absence
wouldn't wreck the story either the big
question is how do they get from where
they are at the end of season one to
that Fireside Feast it does feel very
much like a practice ritual and hunting
Affair so you have to wonder how someone
might find themselves on the wrong side
of that and how the people who are
eating got to the place where that was
the best idea they had a lesser question
is whether all the survivors took part
because we only ever see eight people
around that fateful fire something else
to keep in mind about that is that the
show's descriptions says it Chronicles
their descent from a complicated but
thriving team to Savage Clans the plural
there seems to indicate that we'll see
them break up into different factions to
go a little further the original press
release has a different ending to that
sentence calling them warring
cannibalistic Clans the change in
language makes speculating a little more
confusing but taisa is aversion to
accepting lottie's insights as
Supernatural which may be related to her
own brushes with the strains in that
department that we will be getting into
could make for a natural fault line as
the antler Queen ascends based on their
allegiances in 2021 it seems likely that
Shauna and Natalie were also opposed to
lottie's faction if that's the case if
the people who are following Lottie are
the only ones eating people from the
other Clan how would that not come out
in the years after the rescue if we're
thinking about how they got to that
place then I think we should consider
the one dead human body they habit their
disposal at the end of season one
Jackie's could this be where they first
dip their toes in the water it's
somewhat unlikely considering they just
came across the large reserve of bear
meat but winter has arrived so it's
possible they might not be able to bury
her body just yet I kinda hope she
doesn't become calories but if everyone
has a shared secret they don't want to
get out that might explain why it never
has the other question connected to
Jackie besides who's gonna wear her
necklace now that she's passed is who is
the character that she sees in her final
Vision the way this plays out is that
it's a dying dream and she doesn't
realize what's happening until she sees
Laura Lee who says it's not as bad as
you thought is it then she sees a man in
the doorway behind the group that says
so glad you're joining us we've been
waiting for you this guy is credited as
the Hunter and is the same mysterious
character that appeared in the opening
credits it seems most likely that he's
the dead man man they found in the Attic
in the cabin and that Revelation brings
with it several new questions who is the
we that was waiting for her is he just
talking about him and Laura Lee or are
there others does he merely appear to
the dead if that's what's happening or
is there more paranormal stuff going on
throughout what we've already seen we
don't know why he was there in the first
place why he never left how he died or
if he's the one responsible for the
strange carvings I don't know if he can
expect concrete answers to all of those
things but if he does become a regular
in season two that might mean we'll get
more Jackie as well there was some
speculation that she might not be dead
that was quickly shut down by the show's
creators and they also confirmed the
same for Jessica Roberts Misty had
spiked her cigarettes with fentanyl and
went as far as throwing them away in the
trash because she knew she would ask for
them and then not be suspicious about
them which was kind of insightful she
then let her drive away and we saw that
she started to pass out no D this brings
to mind a couple of questions because as
viewers we know that Tai was the one who
hired her to look into the other Yellow
Jackets Misty may have done her a favor
in tying up that loose end does this
mean that the others will never find out
what Ty gets up to whenever they're not
around the other thing is that room
where Misty kept her looked like it was
already set up for something exactly
like this she's a character that really
wants other people to need her so I have
to wonder if Jessica wasn't the first
person who she kept down there as a
hostage also as we saw when the other
women needed help to get rid of Adam's
Body she knows exactly how to do that I
think it's entirely possible that Misty
could have an even bigger Secret in her
adult life and wouldn't be surprised at
all to find out that she's a serial
killer if that turns out to be the case
then we have to look back to their time
in the wilderness as the most likely
time when she discovered this passion
coach Ben Reese recently broke down and
told her the truth about his feelings
for her so I'm interested to see how
she'll react after that one character
who is probably not dead but is
definitely missing is Hobby the last
time he appeared was during Doom coming
when they were chasing his brother
Shauna saw him hiding and told him to
run and then at the beginning of the
finale Travis told Natalie he was going
to go look for him beyond that he didn't
show up in the finale at all so that's a
question we have going in that could
lead in all sorts of different
directions and speaking of Travis his
death Still Remains a mystery lottie's
name came up from Nat's 12-step
Connection in relation to his bank
account being cleared out but does this
mean she was involved with the murder
remember it was staged as a suicide and
when they saw the photos they noticed
candle wax underneath Travis's body
which was arranged in the shape of the
strange symbol that was in the cabin and
in the woods it's implied that Lottie
was behind the money going missing which
is strange in its own way because
according to Nat he doesn't have any
real connection with her but either way
I don't think you could say for sure
that she was behind this death perhaps
the most interesting question related to
his story in 2021 was the note that
Misty found by rubbing a pencil and a
notepad that she found at his place it
said tell Nat she was right which could
be related to why he was killed if
that's what happened but when Misty
asked that she claims she has no idea
what he was talking about whether Lottie
was involved with his death or not she
does seem to be the most likely suspect
in relation to Nat's kidnapping at the
end the day after they take care of
Adam's Body and attend the reunion
Natalie takes her rifle and points it at
her head she looks ready to take her own
life but can't pull the trigger and then
four people burst into her room at
exactly the right time to drag her out
of there they throw her into a waiting
van and we see that one of them is
wearing a pendant with that strange
symbol after she leaves we hear her
friend from the bank calling and that's
where the idea that Lottie was involved
with emptying the bank account comes
into play throughout the season we see
that Lottie experiences Visions this
goes back to her childhood and we saw
her in an incident where she started
screaming in the back of her parents car
that startled them and it caused them to
miss the light and we see that they also
miss a terrible crash that happened
right in front of them it all looks like
she can see what was about to happen
which we later connect to her Visions
but because her father didn't believe in
that he had her put on medication then
when they go on the trip she runs out of
medication and the Visions come back
quickly several of these seem to come
true and have caught the attention of
the other women I guess the question at
this point isn't whether she has
precognitive abilities but more do the
people around her believe that she does
by the time they get to the pit Girl
scene it appears that some of them are
True Believers so it makes sense that
she might find people to follow her
after they return to civilization and
the people who grabbed Natalie then are
a part of some type of cult that she
leads but what do they want with adult
Natalie then based on the guesses I made
on how the factions might play out
teenage Natalie should have been opposed
to Lottie just as she believed Travis
was
Ty has a ton of crazy stuff going on
most of which can be tied back to what
she calls her sleepwalking we got our
first taste of this when Lottie found
her eating dirt after the plane crash
she claims to have stopped but that it's
continuing to happen now as an adult and
that turned out to be why her son Sammy
was afraid and drawing pictures of the
lady in the tree it's also who he refers
to as the bad one and as things progress
we realized that she goes into a
trance-like state and climbs trees or
eats some dirt or worse but she doesn't
appear to remember what happens it's
something of an alter ego and by the end
of the season it culminates with her
wife Simone following a trail of blood
in their basement and finding an actual
altar in a room you can only get to by
passing through a great she finds the
head and presumably the heart of their
missing dog along with one of Sammy's
dolls who's missing an eye and that
strange symbol painted on the wall
behind them it's freaky and at the same
time she's discovering that we see that
Tai has won her Senate race even though
it looked like she was poised to lose
you can't help but wonder if this is a
sacrifice that's directly connected to
her win and what her wife is gonna do
with this information now that she's
found it many many questions here I
mentioned that Tai was the most vocally
skeptical yellow jacket when it came to
lottie's Visions she puts up a front
that she is convinced that there has to
be a rational explanation to explain
what's happening I think this is likely
compensation for what we saw her
experience in a flashback scene from her
childhood in that we saw her at her
grandmother's side as she was nearing
the end of her life at first she was at
peace saying that death was nothing to
fear because it was just the Lord
calling her back to him later she senses
a presence in the room and starts to
tell it to stay away from her when the
young Thai asks who she yells the man
with no eyes and when she looks in the
mirror a ghostly eyeless figure appears
as an adult I sees him standing in the
crowd when she's talking to the Press
outside her house and he also pops up in
the opening credits the Reddit user fazo
posted what might be a really
interesting connection related to that
they pointed out that Ty stops and looks
into the woods for a extended period of
time at the end of episode 3. the camera
lingers but nothing appears but this
does resemble the same spot where the
man with no eye shows up in the credits
either way the most skeptical of our
characters and the most open among them
both seem to have something Supernatural
going on and the question there has to
be will we ever know for sure the show
obviously likes to play with the tension
that comes from this idea but there may
be no upside in actually explaining
what's happening we'll have to wait and
see because we ended on the note that
maybe Ty's alter ego's sacrifice might
have won her the election and in 1996 we
watched Lottie make the sacrifice of the
Bear's heart to that tree stump she
feels drawn to in the wilderness one
character who doesn't seem to have
anything Supernatural going on with him
is Adam there were a lot of theories
about who this guy might be primarily an
adult hobby or what was going on with
him but in the end he appears to be just
who he said he was which is a shame
since Shauna killed him but beyond lying
about his schooling not much else has
emerged to make him suspicious and so I
wonder was there more going on there or
did he just get into an accident and
fall in love at a really bad time the
other big question about him is whether
or not his murder will come back to
cause trouble for Shauna and Jeff which
would also put Ty Nat and Misty in a bad
spot since they helped dispose of the
body the fact that her daughter Cali
knows about the relationship and that
she saw him on the news would hint at
this part of the story isn't over and it
does feel likely that Shawna and Jeff
will have to deal with an investigation
and speaking of Cali another big
question about Shauna is what happened
to her first pregnancy I mentioned that
she was sleeping with Jackie's boyfriend
and got pregnant before the crash that
of course was with Jeff who became her
husband but he first got her pregnant in
1996. If that first baby lived it would
be in its mid-20s in 2021 so it can't be
the high school age daughter they have
now there's no saying she didn't give
birth to a baby while they were stranded
but remember she journaled about
everything and Jeff admitted to reading
those years ago that all points to a
tragic ending but then maybe hopefully
not too bad since he never brought it up
then again if they ate the baby she
might not commit that to paper so we'll
have to see how that all plays out just
like we'll have to wait and see how many
survivors will be left out there at the
end and how they'll eventually be
rescued it should make for a fun ride
please like the this video If you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon